hi thanks so much for coming to my talk
today i'm katie healey i am currently a
postdoc at duke university under the
supervision of scott schwartzwalder and
the majority of the focus of our lab is
looking at adolescent intermittent
ethanol so we call this aie i'm going to
use that term a lot during this talk but
we're really interested in using a
rodent model to model
adolescent binge drinking
and see what the effects are
both behaviorally and neurobiologically
and we look a lot in the hippocampus
for our neurobiological kind of effects
of adolescent intermittent ethanol
and so i'm going to talk a lot about
that today and talk about the enduring
effects of that on neuroimmune mediators
and specifically cell death machinery
neurogenesis
and some neuro immune
markers that we looked at in the
hippocampus and their reversal by
dinephysial
so first off why do we focus on
adolescence so adolescence we kind of
know this big period of change
and neuro changes right so the onset is
from puberty around 12 13 in the humans
and it actually goes into the mid-20s
especially for males this can go into
the late 20s as well up to about 25
especially for frontal development so
brain development in adolescence is
really important for your function as an
adult and it's a period of rapid changes
so changes really make it very
susceptible to insult and can have
long-term neurological consequences if
you
are during adolescence
exposed to these kind of insults right
so during this period it's really really
susceptible to insult and injury that
can remain throughout the lifetime from
there on out
we kind of all associate adolescence and
there's a reason why with increased
risk-taking and sensation-seeking um so
this period you're just kind of figuring
things out um moving forward doing a lot
of risk-taking sensation-seeking kind of
working into who you're going to be as
an adult right
and so that can involve a lot of
drinking uh and adolescent drinking is
really prevalent here in the us and
actually throughout the world
so
21 of 8th graders 42 of 10th graders and
58 of 12th graders report alcohol use in
the past year uh this has actually gone
up during the pandemic um and so covid
19 and the resulting pandemic and
lockdowns and things like that have
actually escalated drinking behavior
well beyond this even
but binge drinking which we define as
five or more drinks for a male or four
or more drinks for a female in two hours
is really prevalent in adolescence this
seems to be
the pattern of alcohol use that's most
prevalent in adolescence is this kind of
binge drinking behavior and then they go
through these periods of long abstinence
right so they're not drinking every day
but when they do drink they drink in
this binge manner which is kind of heavy
loading in a very short period of time
so five percent of eighth graders 16 of
top 10th graders and even 24 percent of
12th graders kind of engage in this kind
of binge drinking activity
so
an additional study looked at
consumption rates in a subset of 12th
graders
for the past two weeks in this like high
cohort um and what they found is that
greater than 10 percent reported more or
or 10 or more drinks per week
and then an additional 5 reported 15
drinks or more per week so in this small
subsets that are drinking heavily
they're drinking very heavily um and
they're binge drinking right they're not
spreading this out throughout the week
they're doing this on the weekends with
their friends
and then having those periods of
of abstinence right so why do we think
this is a problem
um well we know that adolescent drinking
really induces these persistent
cognitive behavioral and neural changes
um we see this in the human population
so this uh alterations are largely in
the domains of memory and frontal lobe
function so frontal lobe function is
really important for executive function
decision making things like that
and these adolescents that have
these drinking behaviors and these
persistent changes we see increased risk
taking even beyond this
there's executive function deficits
and so this kind of comes out as having
attentional deficits arithmetics issues
facial functioning and working memory
impairments and these
adolescents that use frequently
and what's even more striking about this
is that in previous users who were using
alcohol during adolescence but are now
abstinent these alterations continue
even in after periods of abstinence so
um and here's one of the most um
striking
facts to me and what has made me really
interested in this field actually is
that early adolescent drinking onset is
associated with a four to five fold
increase of developing an alcohol use
disorder within the lifetime so this is
really increasing the odds the earlier
that you start drinking especially binge
drinking can really lead to a
lifetime sometime within the lifetime um
developing an alcohol use disorder so
however um this is a lot of things that
we're talking about with humans and
alcohol is not always used in isolation
and often is not used in isolation um
and can be
compounded by other comorbid drug use
you know some people drink when they
smoke or things like that so there can
be nicotine and alcohol on board and so
in order to kind of
really pinpoint what are the effects of
alcohol drinking um in adolescence we
really look to animal models in order to
be able uh to look at this and see what
are the exact effects of alcohol without
pot the potential of these other
comorbid drug use
occurring as well
and so what's really great is that
adolescence is a period that's conserved
across many mammalian species so brain
maturation during adolescence is really
well conserved across
mammals
and we've shown that previously so
things that we mean in this brain
maturation would be neural pruning is
conserved we see this gray matter volume
reduction as adolescence continues and
white matter volume increase and this is
well conserved across species
we see this peak
activity in the mesolimbic dopamine
system right this is the reward system
this is very active during adolescence
and we see this across species
there's also less inhibition on the
prefrontal cortex compared to um when in
adulthood so right you have this peak in
your reward seeking kind of circuitry
and this inhibition of the prefrontal
cortex and we see this conserved across
species
and the hypersensitivity to the receipt
of reward this is something where um
you're just activated more and you're
more sensitive to to getting that where
the the pleasurable effects of that
reward
and there's this really critical aspect
of social context and this is shown
throughout our um species right
especially i use more of rodent which
we'll get into um and social
um
play and social interaction is is hugely
important across mammals mammalian
species
so how do we then bring this into
rodents so we use rats in our lab um how
do we model this in menstruating we know
that adolescence is conserved and rats
very similarly as into humans so we know
that this is a good um model for us to
use but now how do we do it right how do
we make them drink
um and so the thing is is that um the
adolescents in rats is uh much quicker
than in humans obviously so
pmd stands for postnatal day and so
adolescence spans from approximately
postnatal day 28 to 55 um in the rat and
so this is a little bit conservative
they can go a little bit further or be a
little bit earlier
but this is you know the main range of
adolescents in the rat
and we use various methods of
administration of ethanol
so
adolescent rats are actually a little
bit smarter than adolescent humans they
don't tend to just self-administer
alcohol readily or to the binge levels
that human adolescents will use and so
we use various models of administration
to kind of experimentally experiment or
administered alcohol right so you can do
intergastric which is to actually place
the ethanol into the stomach and that is
what we use um there's also
some inhalation
or you can use an intraperitoneal
injection or there's other oral ways
that you can kind of make them like
force them to drink it um but the
interject gastric is where you place it
directly into the stomach and that is
what we use we find this to be a really
good model because it allows the
ethanol to be absorbed into the system
similarly as it would be into a human
adolescence um you know through the
gastric system
we use an intermittent schedule right so
they're not getting alcohol every day
and this is to binge those same periods
in human adolescence where you see the
uh use high levels of use on one day but
then they go through periods of
abstinence right so to do that we do a
two days on one to two days off schedule
which i'll get into a little bit more
and so binge levels are at greater than
80
milligrams per deciliter of blood plasma
that would mean that they hit a binge
level um that's uh by the national
institute of alcohol and alcohol abuse
um and so in our model we tend to use uh
intragastric
where we give five milligrams per
kilogram of ethanol this really gives us
a reliable to approximately 200
milligrams per deciliter so they are
really going um a lot higher and this is
really looking at that heavy binge
drinking in these animals and we give
them 10 doses over 16 days um and so
that models that two days on well either
one to two days off and we
dose them from pnd date 30 to 46 so
right kind of in the middle of this
adolescent span in these
animals
and so we know that by using these
methods we get similar alterations in
the hippocampus and adulthood that we
find in the human population so within
the hippocampus we've seen learning and
memory deficits as i had said were
previously shown in the adolescent human
population we also see volume decreases
in the hippocampus and other areas in
both clinical and preclinical work
alteration in hippocampal inputs there
are changes in morphology in the
hippocampus and there's increased immune
signaling so we know that this is a
pretty good model for adolescent binge
drinking in our rodent population
and so we and others that we collaborate
with in other labs as well have found
that aie so again this is that
adolescent intermittent snl modeling in
the rodent population so i'll be calling
it aie so aie reduces cholinergic
innervation into the hippocampus um so
within the basal forebrain which is
called ch1n2 these guys send the
cholinergic input into the hippocampus
and they are the primary um innervator
of cholinergic input into the
hippocampus
this is really important for facility
memory related neuronal function again
the hippocampus and we focus a lot on
the dorsal hippocampus which is
important for spatial
memory and function and so
um this uh projection of cholinergic
innervation is really really
integral for this memory related
neuronal function
you can look at choline
acetyltransferase also called cat and
this is a marker for cholinergic inner
neurons or neurons not just in their
outside and what we have found is that
in the hippocam or in the ch one and two
sorry um these this is the area that
projects to the dorsal hippocampus the
ch one and two animals that receive
either water which are labeled here as
controls they are not getting ethanol in
adolescence or aie adolescent
intermittent ethanol
that cat immunoreactivity is reduced in
ch1 and 2. and this is really indicating
that there is reduced innervation into
the hippocampus cholinergic innervation
um to be specific and so it creates this
chronic depression of this cholinergic
input into the hippocampal circuits and
actually one thing that um a
collaborator of ours has shown recently
but has not published yet um is that
these neurons um in this region so in ch
one and two
they're actually not reduced so this
reduction in cat marker
and immunoreactivity in the ch1 and 2 is
not actually indicative of a reduction
of neurons so it's the same number of
neurons they just seem to be changed
into
a different type of neurons they're no
longer expressing cat but they may be
expressing other um
neurotransmitters and things like that
so so this is really interesting and
something that we're moving forward with
it's not a complete reduction of this
region but it's just a reduction in cats
and so we have also found that
in the hippocampus so now we're moving
from ch1 and 2 which provides that
cholinergic input into the hippocampus
now looking at the hippocampus we have
found reduced neurons in the hippocampus
in an immune an increased immune
response in ca1 or the dentate virus um
we're sorry nca1 so
we found reduced neural numbers in the
hippocampus following
aie so this is again i don't think i
made this um completely specific but we
are looking in adulthood so uh adulthood
starts at postnatal day 70 um or greater
and so here we have given these animals
aie and adolescence from pnd 30 to 46
but now we have let them age up into
adulthood and here we're seeing um this
reduction in neural numbers in the
hippocampus these are you know
persistent changes
that continues so and we've also looked
at some immune response such as
astrocytes
so these guys are really integral for
synaptic formation connectivity and
really the function of the hippocampus
as it goes with um working with um in
the tripartite synapse
and so we have found that astrocytes are
actually
more reactive and so reactive astrocytes
are larger and so after aie we see these
larger astrocytes as you can see in this
bottom right corner here
follow in adulthood so this is kind of a
persistent change that we see that's
showing a reduction in the number of
neurons and this kind of increased
immuno inflammatory response and a
pattern of immune response in the
hippocampus following this history of
aie so looking in adulthood
so we've also found that there is a loss
of neuro
or adult neuroimmune activation and then
the loss of neurogenesis so neurogenesis
is new neurons being formed right and we
look at that through the uh a marker
double cortine um so we're looking at
double coordinate immunoreactivity here
our control animals who received water
and adolescence are in the open bars and
the aie animals are in the close bars so
if we look here in the left panel
looking at the no exercise group that's
closest to the y-axis we can see that
with no exercise so kind of a standard
model of aie we see this reduction in
double corten immunoreactivity after aie
in adulthood what was really exciting
about this is that if you look at the
exercise group so this was um a model of
prevention we see that um the aie
animals look just like those water
controls and we actually can reverse
these changes in the hippocampus and
this reduction in neurogenesis which is
really exciting because it shows that
even though these changes are very
persistent and they continue into
adulthood they are reversible right
and so what we're also looking at here
is cleaved caspase immunoreactivity
and what we see is that uh so this is a
death receptor uh this is a a marker of
cell death right um and so what we see
is that this marker of cell death is
increased um
in um aie animals in these darker bars
compared to the control animals however
exercise is um reduces this elevation in
the aie animal so again it is reversed
by exercise
and another
type of cell um
immunoreactivity we're looking here at
nf kappa b
and so what we see here is that on the
left panel and the no exercise group the
aie animals have elevated um nf kappa b
and adulthood immunoreactivity and that
this can again be reversed by exercise
so we see these alterations that are
caused by aie that persist into
adulthood but again they are
able to be reversed by exercise so they
are reversible
and so from this where we see this
reduced cholinergic innervation increase
in inflammatory response or reduce cell
population i'm going to increase cell
death and reduce neurogenesis and the
dentate gyrus um we um and
wanted to again
look at um these in our model and it we
also had some other information sorry
forgot about this slide here where we're
going to talk about the neural immune
changes that occurred in the prefrontal
cortex that
also implicates some more of these
neuroimmune responses so in the human
we see
rage which is um
a receptor
for damps danger associated molecular
proteins pathways uh and so this will
elevate kind of our cell death machinery
as well and hmgb1 is an activator of
rage tl4 so we see these all um increase
in the human alcoholic in the prefrontal
cortex we've also seen it in the
uh in our adolescent
rats and so this brought in
our want to kind of look at these
markers in the hippocampus as well right
so um we have our double chord in our
neurogenesis that is reduced after aiu
and the hippocampus that we know as well
as some cellular death markers and then
additionally this could be looking at
more of a mechanism if we look at rage
and hmg b1 which can be these activators
of these um
cell death machinery so
what we wanted to know is that could we
replicate this in the hippocampal
neuroimmune and neurogenesis deficits
and can we reverse these effects and we
wanted to reverse these effects
pharmacologically um not with exercise
and so we looked to dinephyseal which is
also known as aeroscept this is a
selective reversible cholenesterase
inhibitor um so we really wanted to
target this kind of reduced innervation
into the hippocampus and see if this is
what's kind of causing these learning
and memory deficits
um so this is used clinically to combat
memory related
cognitive de deficits
especially specifically working memory
deficits and we this has been used in
several animal models as well as
obviously it's fda approved and
clinically used
so adult rats with the history of aid
have that reduced cholinergic
innervation into the hippocampus we
thought that we could possibly reverse
this using dinephoso okay so for our
study design um we used intragastric
gabage
our animals arrived on pnd 25 and then
they habituated to the colony room until
pnd 30 when they began their aie
treatment again this is two days on one
day off two days on two days off um for
16 days so it gives 10 doses over 16
days from pnd 30 to 30-46 they received
they aged up into adulthood um and then
they received uh two and a half
milligrams per kilogram um of again
intergastric gabage of dinephysial for
four days and they were sacrificed two
hours after their last dose so the
targets that we looked at were
targets of neurogenesis cell death
machinery neuroimmune signaling
epigenetic markers and again we were
looking for this reversal binding
episode in these studies that i will
explain
so first off we wanted to
replicate that dcx so that marker of
neurogenesis that had been found
previously and so what we found was that
aie exposure reduces
in the dentate dryers neurogenesis
and this was reversed by nine episodes
so if we look over here at our graph we
see that we have gcx immunoreactivity
in our open bars we have animals that
were treated with vehicle which was
water and then in the black bars we have
the animals that are treated with
dinephysial we have aiaw um in the first
grouping on the y our x-axis and aie and
the second grouping and so what you can
see
is that animals that were treated with
vehicle and had a history of aie have
reduced dcx immunoreactivity compared to
their water controls but uh dinepizzle
reversed this deficit and was able to
make these animals look similar to their
water treated controls all right and
over here on the right we just have the
um
representation of the immunodcx
immunoreactivity
and so this is a marker of neurogenesis
and we're seeing that there's reduced
neurogenesis in the dentate virus after
aig but this can be reversed by good
enough as well
so this is a reduction of new neurons
that is reversible
we then wanted to look at some uh cell
death machinery in the dentate gyrus as
well um and see if this was reversed by
dinebasal so we looked at active
caspase-3 immunoreactivity
and we again saw that in our ai treated
animal water treated
aie treated vehicle animals there was
this elevation of activated caspase-3
immunoreactivity that was then reversed
by
uh treatment with dinephysial in
adulthood right so this is so important
because our treatment is an adulthood
after these persistent changes have
occurred and lasted for about 25 days
and then treatment reverses these
alterations and so on the right hand
side here you can see um our
representative images
and then we also looked at um death
receptor three this is another
cell death machinery marker and so what
we see is that this is very elevated in
our aie treated vehicle animals and that
this was reversed by treatment with
dinnepassal
so both of these cell death markers can
be
um they are elevated after aie in
adulthood and they are reversible by
genetical
so we also wanted to look at some
neuroimmune function and start to get at
the mechanism behind what this is how
this is happening so we started to look
at epigenetic plasticity again and here
we are in the
dentate gyrus
so first off we looked at nf kappa b
we again found that this was elevated
after aie and reversed by genetical so
nf kappa b is really important for
cytokine production and immune response
regulation so this elevation is showing
this elevation of an neuroimmune
function after aie but then again
reversal vitamin episode
we looked at pro-inflammatory gene
activation so this is the rage receptor
um this is elevated after aie and then
again reversed by dinephysial
and hmgb1 is one of the activators of
the rage receptor
and this is the only one that we can
because i probably am starting to sound
like a
kind of broken record here reverse
binding episode but this was not
reversed by
um
dinephyseal so this is a danger
associated molecular pathway um
uh agent and so as we see here and it is
not affected by aiw or water treatment
with nepal but in our ai treated animals
it is elevated and this is not reversed
by dinephysial so
um and hmgb1 has some like really
interesting signaling and methods on
which it goes so this is actually really
interesting that it's not been reversed
by deniphizo and cause for some future
investigation
but lastly we looked at the an
epigenetic marker so this is kind of an
indicative of repressed transcription
and what we found is that after aie and
adulthood if they are treated with water
we find this elevation
of h3k9 methylated two
amino reactivity and that this again was
reduced by dinephazil and no different
than the water-treated controlled
animals
so this is kind of starting to paint
this picture for us of potential
mechanisms by which we find this
reduction
of neurogenesis and elevation of cell
death machinery within the hippocampus
and it's kind of giving us a little bit
of a hint that we should be
investigating you know these elevation
and rage receptors and its associated
activator as hmgb1 as well as nf kappab
which can cause you know this elevation
of immune responses and has a lot of um
downstream signaling and this epigenetic
marker showing repressed transcription
kind of gives us this really great new
area that we should be kind of heading
into so this is the potential mechanisms
that we're going to be investigating
behind this reduced
neurogenesis and increased cell death
and so just in summary um we went
through today kind of um some seminal
findings that we had in the hippocampus
and the dentate gyrus
where we showed that aie reduced
neurogenesis
and this was reversed by dinephysial
additionally we found that aiea exposure
increased cell death machinery um in the
dentate gyrus and this was reversed by
dinephyl then we started to look into
the mechanism of how this neurogenesis
and cell death machinery alterations are
caused by aie and we kind of looked into
neuroimmune function and epigenetic
plasticity and the dentate gyrus we
found that for the most part an episode
reverses alterations except for hmg b1
and so this is leading us into some
future directions where we're going to
continue to kind of look at the
mechanism behind the neurogenesis
deficits and increase neuroimmune
signaling of aie we want to
kind of continue to figure out what is
the direct mechanism behind all of this
and we also want to take these findings
and kind of
look into the prefrontal for cortex and
see if we see these alterations and if
they are reversed by dinephosol our lab
has recently been taking kind of a more
astrocytic component as well so we do
want to look in both the hippocampus and
the prefrontal cortex to look at the
astrocytic involvement which is what
we've been doing most recently
so with that i just want to say thank
you to my lab i am again a post-doc in
the swartz welder lab so i work with
scott schwartzwalder and again our
awesome technicians and
um undergraduates uh sandra kibble kyra
dubster sarah hodges amelia bell george
kramer as well as our collaborators
fault include cruz um wen liu and sean
atchison who helped get this project and
of course our funding
we are a part of the neurobiology of
adolescent drinking and adulthood
consortium the nadia consortium who
primarily funded this work through
ni aaa
and these funding sources so thank you
for coming to my talk